[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora ragazzi io mi sono guardato
intorno e ho visto come vanno le cose
devo dirvi che non ci siamo devo
parlarvi quindi assolutamente del coso
se insomma del così non avete capito
quello che si mette si indossa si mette
lì si infilano da sopra se in fila cioè
prima si apre e poi si infila capito
cioè lo devi un po srotolare
naturalmente insomma avete capito di
cosa sto parlando
dai come lo chiamate il cappotto ok il
soprabito no non quello vero quello di
gomma insomma l'impermeabile ok allora
come lo chiama il preservativo
su dai non è una parolaccia
eppure in italia
cinque giovani sessualmente attivi su
dieci non lo usano proprio e addirittura
due su cinque non fanno ricorso a
nessuna precauzione
durante rapporti sessuali
punto di partenza ad avere in mente per
tutto il discorso e poi capirete il
perché di tanta importanza
esistono diversi metodi contraccettivi
la pillola la spirale per citarne alcuni
ma solo il preservativo è l'unico
dispositivo anche in grado di prevenire
il contagio la trasmissione di infezioni
sessualmente trasmissibili
che sono oltre 20
si parla poco di sesso quindi si parla
poco di preservativo ma è proprio la
scarsa informazione sui rischi per la
salute in termini di infezioni
sessualmente trasmissibili che causa la
noncuranza sul potente impatto che
queste infezioni potrebbero avere sulla
vita di ciascuno di noi
facciamo un passo indietro di qualche
anno
il regista pier paolo pasolini
registrò un documentario dal titolo
comizi d'amore un'inchiesta sugli
italiani e sulla sessualità
durante l'intervista il regista chiese a
un protagonista una persona trovata per
strada chiese ma secondo lei problemi
sessuali vanno trattati esplicitamente o
è meglio tacere piccola parentesi
pasolini e di bologna io sono di rimini
quindi l'accento credo mi sia riuscito
abbastanza bene ma immaginate per un
romagnolo come me citare così spesso la
parola sesso che sono cinque lettere tra
esse la gioia proprio
ma torniamo a noi la risposta a quella
domanda è stata per me è meglio tacere
è una risposta molto forte ma sarà
ancora più forte quando vi dirò l'anno
del film è stato
1964 sono passati ormai sessant'anni
eppure quella risposta rimane purtroppo
ancora molto attuale e lo rimane per il
nemico più grande del sesso che non è il
mostro cattivo che si nasconde sotto al
letto quando spegniamo la luce prima di
andare a letto ma è la vergogna
sempre rispetto allo stesso film
il registra introduce l'intervallo
scrivendo non c'è niente di più faticoso
che di parlare di sesso e aveva proprio
ragione questa fatica è legata alla
vergogna i giovani ancora si imbarazzano
a comprare i preservativi è soltanto uno
su due ha trattato almeno una volta con
i genitori l'argomento prevenzione
purtroppo
i genitori
loro stessi non hanno le competenze e
non sono in grado di parlare coi figli
tralasciando quello che è il distacco
generazionale i problemi di
comunicazione ma la formazione che
dovrebbero dare ai propri figli sin dai
primi anni della loro esistenza anche in
campo della sessualità non ce l'hanno e
quindi rischiamo di trovarci nella
situazione dove un non vedente prova a
guidare un non vedente senza successo
e queste sono le famiglie ancora in cui
si prova a parlare di sesso ma ci sono
famiglie in cui proprio non se ne parla
ma ricordiamoci che tacere non è altro
che un metodo per comunicare che di
sesso non si deve proprio parlare e
quindi aggravare ancora di più il
percorso formativo dei bambini e degli
adolescenti
la scuola sembra essere ad oggi il luogo
ideale dove poter iniziare a parlare
dell'argomento
intorno ai 15 anni abbiamo l'età media
del primo rapporto in italia è l'età in
cui si formano i primi contatti col
sesso opposto con lo stesso sesso col
sesso che via da qui e ciascuno viene
attratto questo è il mio liceo io mi
sono ho avuto la maturità qualche anno
fa nel nel 2008 è stato un anno in cui
l'italia agli europei non è andata
particolarmente bene siamo usciti ai
quarti contro la spagna per i rigori
però un paio di anni prima qualche
soddisfazione ce la siamo presa ai
mondiali
in tutto in cinque anni ho avuto 5 mila
ore di didattica e una sola ora di
educazione sessuale lo 0,02 per cento
praticamente nulla direi anche perché è
proprio l'ignoranza che porta a
commettere
certe azioni e certi argomenti
verrebbero come se molte meno leggerezze
se fossimo davvero a conoscenza delle
conseguenze di certe azioni
tralasciando la pochezza delle ore con
cui sono stato formato la domanda è ma è
proprio la scuola superiore il luogo
ideale
probabilmente addirittura no è fin
troppo tardi perché
il cambiamento del corpo avviene già
nell'età della pubertà quindi lo
spiegare ai bambini perché il loro corpo
sta cambiando perché il corpo dei loro
amici ed allora mi che sta cambiando e
imparare il concetto del rapporto del
rispetto per se stessi verso gli altri
verso il potenziale o futuro partner è
fondamentale per crescere quegli
adolescenti e bambini come adolescenti
ragazzi adulti e futuri genitori in modo
che anche a loro volta possano essere
formati per poter raccontare con
coscienza alle persone quanto è
importante
proteggersi in termini di contagio di
infezioni sessualmente trasmissibili
anche la chiesa cattolica si è espressa
a favore dell'educazione sessuale nelle
scuole proprio perché i genitori non
dispongono nella maggior parte dei casi
di di strumenti adeguati
e se l'ho detto anche la chiesa
cattolica allora agiamo agiamo sin da
subito perché non è solo urgente ma non
è più procrastinabile perché
l'alternativa non è positiva è internet
all internet come lo chiama qualcuno
dove la fec news è dietro l'angolo
ora qui vi ho riportato una
estremizzazione del che ho trovato sul
compianto yahoo lancer
ecco anche questa è stata la prima
reazione che ho avuto io ma non diamo
mai per scontato che un adolescente a
quell'età si è in grado di distinguere
cosa in realtà è cosa è finzione
e questo è il minore dei mali perché
insieme a internet vero c'è anche tanto
informazioni di qualità sui siti
istituzionali ma c'è un'altra pericolosa
insidia che è la pornografia
da un lato nella pornografia non viene
utilizzato il preservativo e quindi
questo non fa altro che continuare a
costruire negativamente sugli stereotipi
legati al suo utilizzo è a minimizzarne
l'importanza dall'altro lato ancora più
grave nella pornografia si si crea una
mistificazione della realtà che non fa
altro che lavorare su un ansia legata ai
rapporti e ancora peggio sul concetto di
sesso come dominio dell'altro dove nella
maggior parte dei casi è dominio
dell'uomo sulla donna
in un recente articolo apparso su
repubblica alessandro d'avenia descrive
gli per colpi del porno come macchine di
potere dell'orgasmo continue perfetto
che impongono un immaginario di dominio
che esclude la fragilità le paure i
difetti dei corpi veri wow forte ma
assolutamente vera quindi sommando un po
tutto la situazione dove ci troviamo
fino al 2020 non è proprio rosea in
termini di educazione sessuale e dico
2020 perché arriva una grandissima altre
botta per quella che è la sessualità
degli italiani e non solo la pandemia
otto italiani su dieci durante la
pandemia hanno fatto meno sesso
abbiamo le coppie che si sono ritrovate
anche in situazioni forzose sotto lo
stesso tetto dalla mattina alla sera e
le situazioni forzose non contribuiscono
alla rilassatezza e anche ad avere
rapporti oppure coppie che si sono
trovate forzatamente distanziate a lungo
dove non si sono potute incontrare
ancora peggio è andata ai single che non
hanno avuto assolutamente modo di poter
conoscere nuovi e potenziali partner
durante il periodo
però durante la pandemia è esplosa la
mascherina che voi tutti oggi avete
addosso abbiamo iniziato ad averla dalla
mattina alla sera abbiamo iniziato a
capire quanto è importante avere questo
come dispositivo di protezione
durex come azienda pensava che questa
aumentata attenzione alla prevenzione si
trasferisse anche su tutto quello che
riguardava altri tipi di infezioni e
contagi
eppure così non è successo perché a tre
mesi dall'inizio della pandemia in una
ricerca è emerso che la maggior parte
degli italiani non ha cambiato le
proprie abitudini in temi di igiene
prevenzione nonostante non ci fossero
rapporti non avevano la propensione a
cambiarle e quindi da una parte era
l'occasione per sensibilizzare però
dall'altra come potete immaginare 8
rapporti in meno su 10 in un periodo di
crisi bisognerebbe ridurre gli
investimenti ed è qui che scatta invece
il piano b di durex grazie alla tendenza
alla sensibilizzazione alla prevenzione
si decide di investire ancora di più in
una campagna che si chiama non torniamo
alla normalità sottolinea il nonno
perché è molto in controtendenza con
tante retoriche che a lungo sono
diventate anche banali di torniamo alla
normalità torniamo al più presto
chiunque di noi voleva e vuole tornare
alle abitudini sane però c'è qualcosa
che vogliamo cambiare rispetto al
periodo pre pandemia perché non era
tutto ok il fatto che circolassero
liberamente infezioni sessualmente
trasmissibili e solo una persona su due
utilizzasse il condom non era ok quello
vogliamo lasciarlo in lockdown è per
questo che arriva il messaggio di
rottura della marca
insieme a questo è stata lanciata una
task force di esperti medico scientifici
che sono stati che hanno realizzato un
decalogo di buone pratiche per una
sessualità consapevole che possa essere
immortale negli anni non era legato alla
pandemia ma che è stato l'inizio è
iniziato a circolare
durante questo periodo e lo faremo nel
corso dei prossimi anni
in più durante
per quanto riguarda la comunicazione il
lato social la marca è famosa per quello
che riguarda la comunicazione in realta
in marketing ovvero prendere un trend
farlo proprio e utilizzarlo per fare una
comunicazione pubblicitaria
chiaramente durante la pandemia per sei
mesi non si è parlato di altro che di
questo quindi sono venuti a meno i trend
e allora ci si addetti ma è giusto
possiamo comunicare durante questo
periodo drammatico come apparso sin
dall'inizio con il tono di voce
irriverente che la marca si porta un po
dietro
abbiamo fatto dei piccoli testa
all'inizio i risultati sono stati
estremamente positivi quindi ci siamo
detti che anche lato social era
possibile utilizzare il momento per
contribuire a quella che era la
sensibilizzazione alla prevenzione
sperando veramente che questo possa
possiamo portarselo dietro da come
comportamento dopo la pandemia e in
particolare questo post che immagino la
maggior parte di voi abbia visto è stato
ri condiviso da tantissime in
innumerevoli persone e da tantissimi
influencer e in maniera gratuita e
vi giuro che non è semplice perché ormai
si pagano anche per e spie si fanno
pagare anche per respirare quindi vedere
una condivisione così forte di un post
del genere è successo perché hanno
capito il messaggio dietro a questo
posto era un messaggio di salute
pubblica di raccomandazione di
prevenzione e quindi lo hanno fatto e
questo dimostra che c'è volontà di
contribuire alla causa e al messaggio
tiriamo le somme la pandemia è stato un
periodo in cui ogni essere umano ha
vissuto e sta vivendo una trasposizione
da una situazione di libertà a una
situazione di limitazioni tuttora in
corso ed è un periodo in cui come scrive
repubblica avremmo forse avuto bisogno
di più abbracci l'abbraccio che era non
solo proibito ma addirittura in certi
periodi in legale quell'abbraccio che
noi italiani piace tanto perché ci piace
anche quando ci salutiamo anche dopo
tanto tempo che non ci vediamo avere un
gesto tattile e anche perché l'abbraccio
non fa altro che liberare ossitocina che
è un ormone che contribuisce ad
abbassare i livelli di ansia nello
stress quindi ce ne vorrebbero
eppure al momento ancora non si può non
si può ma siamo ancora nella fase in cui
possiamo
sfruttare il momento per ragionare
interiorizzare sempre di più il concetto
di prevenzione dalla mascherina al
preservativo e quando sarà possibile
tornare tornare a fare sesso di poterlo
veramente utilizzare del capire del
perché e dell'importanza di poterlo
utilizzare
comunicare il preservativo il sesso non
è semplice ce lo siamo già detti la
situazione con forti tabù scarsa
informazione era già
era già deteriorata si imprima della
pandemia ma è avvenuta una bellissima
novità a fine 2020 ovvero una nuova
legislazione che permette una
comunicazione del preservativo più
facile semplificata proprio per andare a
prevenire quelli che potrebbero essere i
contagi e lo permette metterà anche di
comunicare nei luoghi fisici ma
soprattutto digitali dove sono oggi
giovani alla loro nell'età della loro
prima volta 13 14 15 anni come ad
esempio i social network twitch e tic
toc
la pandemia 15 offre una possibilità per
poter lasciare lockdown le infezioni
sessualmente trasmissibili e i
comportamenti sbagliati
prendiamola questa opportunità ognuno di
noi di voi sin da oggi può veramente
agire in maniera positiva il cambiamento
fa parte di tutti noi perché più ne
parliamo più normalizzare mo l'argomento
sesso più se ne parlerà liberamente
in italia ogni anno ci sono ancora 3
mila nuove infezioni di hiv oi anche a
fine di questa giornata purtroppo
conteremo ancora otto nuovi contagi ed è
per questo che è importantissimo e
urgente agire non è più procrastinabile
anche perché se ci pensate per agire
basta tanto così
[Applauso]